it says which of the following could be
a primitive function for this guy f dash
x equals four e to the ax all right now
if I want to find the period of function
what I'm doing is I'm integrating and I
can say for e to the 8 X with respect to
X
there's my integral alright now
remembering that when we differentiate
we multiply by the inside derivative in
this case I need to not x divided so if
I'm dividing here
I'm not going to multiply by 8 I'm going
to divide by 8 so I'm going to say that
the solution here will be 4 e to the 8x
on 8 plus my constant of integrate
integration so you can see my 4 in my
edit gonna cancel that gives me 1/2 e to
the 8x plus C which means that one of
the potential primitive function which
matches that is going to be having a
look at my solutions here Part A that's
the one that will work for me a one away
the other way that you could think about
this by the way is to go from this
original line here and say that I would
like my thing to look like 8 e to the 8x
because I can see there this is in the
form f dash X e to the f of X it's a
standard form and you can see that from
the reference sheet of course you can't
just change a 4 into an 8 because you'll
want to because it's convenient to you I
need to make this equivalent to what I
started with so in order to compensate
for the fact that I just multiplied by 2
I need to multiply by 1/2 to make up for
that so you can see in my 1/2 times my
aunt would give me the 4 that was in the
original question and because this is
just a standard form the 1/2 is out the
front and it directly gives me e to the
X plus C same answer just another way to
think about it all right here we've got
a reverse chain rule and so you have to
think quite carefully about how this is
going to work it's very easy there's
lots of traps for young players for how
to often think about chain rule instead
of reverse chain rule so we're going to
do this nice and slowly when we
differentiate if I were to think about
for example let's do a counter example
over here if I were differentiating
something
looks like this if I had say 3x - 1 ^
say let's put a nine up there okay what
are the steps we're going to go through
well let's remember we're going to
differentiate the inside which would
give me three and then I would
differentiate the outside so this is
going to be bringing index at the front
then reduce that index by one and then
we're finished so we're gonna do exactly
this but in the reverse order okay so
let's have a look at this guy
over here I'm going to increase the
power the last thing that we did when I
was doing this example question of the
chain rule was decrease that index this
so I'm going to increase so that gives
me 4x + 3 - power of 7 so I've increased
the power the previous thing I did was I
multiplied whoops I multiplied by that
old index well now I'm going to divide
by the new int X let me say that one
more time is quite confusing in there
chain rule you multiply by the old index
in the reverse chain rule you divide by
the new index so this is going to be
divided by 7 and then finally to
complete things the very first thing
that I did when I was differentiating by
chain rule was I multiplied by the
inside derivative well in this case I'm
not going to multiply by the inside
derivative I'm gonna divide by the
inside derivative in this case the
inside function is 4 X plus 3 and so my
inside derivative is going to be 4 and
you might wanna ask why have I written
multiply instead of divide well because
I'm writing on the denominator I'm
actually dividing when you multiply the
denominator by increasingly large
numbers so you can see that the
denominator is going to simplify to 28
and I have my constant of integration
there because it's an indefinite
integral
so therefore this clearly matches to
answer D alright now let's have a go at
question Tim this is a bit sneaky you
didn't get to do this question in the
exam because there was a minor
typographical error that prevented you
from getting the right solution but I'm
going to show it to you now as was
originally
intended they give you this function
here dy on DX equals 3 minus 2 over x
squared they tell you it's a gradient
function so now they ask what is the
equation of the curve if it passes
through the point 1 comma negative 2 now
remember if you get given a function and
you want to go to the gradient function
you differentiate but this time they
give you the gradient function and they
want you to go back to the original so
instead of differentiating that's why we
need to integrate because that reverses
this process so I'm going to write y
equals the integral of 3 minus 2 over x
squared and this is not written in a
form that's sort of nice to integrate
right now instead I'm going to write it
with negative indices we usually avoid
negative indices but in this instant
once when you're integrating it makes it
easier to think about how the rule works
so that's integrating with respect to X
now 3 is just going to become 3x I've
increased the index and divided by the
new index which is 1 over 1 so that's
why I didn't write it and then I do the
same thing for this guy so be careful
because you're a lot of negatives flying
around the minus 2 comes in first and
now I'm going to increase the index and
then divide by the new index so be very
careful when you add 1 to negative 2 you
get negative 1 and then when you divide
by that index you've got negative 1 on
the denominator plus C of course because
this is an indefinite integral so this
is a bit of a mess I want to simplify
this a little more it's going to give me
3x there's a double negative
here with here so therefore I'm just
going to get a plus 2 is on the
numerator that X to the power of
negative 1 on the numerator becomes X on
the denominator and then I say plus C
now this is an indefinite integral so
that plus C could be anything except for
the fact that the question is told us
extra information it tells us that this
function y equals 3x plus 2 over X
see it passes through a particular point
1 comma negative 2 now when you think
about corner geometry what that is is an
x value paired up with a y value so what
they're telling you is when x equals 1 y
equals negative 2 you can combine those
two together that's why we call them
coordinates because they sort of coexist
so I'm gonna write that I'm gonna say
when x equals 1 y equals negative 2 and
I'm gonna substitute that in to this
line here my indefinite integral and
that will let me find out the value of C
and then I'll determine which solution I
need so let's have a go y is negative 2
so I'll write that on the left-hand side
I've got 3 lots of 1 plus 2 over 1 plus
C a little more tidying up to do here so
the negative 2 is still there on the
left-hand side that's a 3 that's a 2 2
plus 3 is 5 and now if I subtract 5 from
both sides I get C left alone on its own
on the right and then negative 7 over
there so what that tells me is coming
back to this line up here I can
substitute in the value for C that we've
found so y equals 3x plus 2 over X take
away 7 which you can see is part